[Música]
actualizamos la economía del mundo en
directo América de Francia 24 Juan Pablo
lucuni nuevamente con nosotros Juan
Pablo ya se conoció hace pocos minutos
el dato de inflación en Estados Unidos
en cuanto se ubica esta casa Así es
acabamos de conocer el dato pues la
inflación de Estados Unidos volvió a
bajar en septiembre por tercer mes
consecutivo y su tasa se situó de manera
interna anual en el
8,2%. una décima menos que en agosto
cuando esta fue del 8,3%. según los
datos publicados este jueves por la
oficina de estadísticas laborales los
datos aunque son bajos no son los
esperados por la reserva Federal Pues el
banco esperaba un 8,1% con esto los
mercados han reaccionado de manera
negativa Pues como no cumplió las
expectativas de la Fed puede que las
tasas de interés vuelvan a subir una vez
más el Banco Central de Estados Unidos
ya ha aumentado los tipos de interés
cinco veces este año incluidos tres
aumentos del 0,75%.
Hablamos ahora de energía y qué le
espera al mercado Petro al mercado
petrolero luego de recorte que anunció
la OPEP la semana pasada del recorte de
la producción de los barriles así de
Raúl pues este jueves salió el informe
mensual de la agencia internacional de
energía y sus perspectivas de demanda de
crudo son en general a la baja cuáles
son sus previsiones Pues según la
agencia la demanda global de crudo para
octubre noviembre y diciembre será de
340,000 barriles diarios de petróleo
petróleo mucho menor que el último
trimestre de 2021 esperan que la demanda
total para este 2022 sea de 99,6
millones de barriles lo que representa
60.000 menos que las provisiones que se
anunciaron en el mes pasado y estiman
que el consumo global para el próximo
año sea de 1,7 millones de barriles
diarios de petróleo también muy por
debajo de los 1,9 millones que se
esperaban Pues para el cierre de este
año
el gobierno del reino de Arabia Saudita
también quisiera aclarar que con
respecto a la situación en los mercados
petroleros el gobierno del reino aclaró
a través de su continua consulta con la
administración estadounidense que todos
los análisis económicos indicaban que
posponer la decisión de la OPEP más por
un mes según los sugerido habría tenido
consecuencias económicas negativas
hablamos de la inflación en Estados
Unidos Juan Pablo Pero hablamos a hablar
de la de Alemania porque se conoció el
dato de septiembre Así es la una de las
economías más importantes de Europa Pues
el dato lo dio la oficina Federal de
estadísticas de ese país reportando una
cifra que no se veía en 70 años en
septiembre la tasa se ubicó en 10%
interanual pero miremos como mes a mes
el costo de vida de los alemanes se ha
ido incrementando en junio fue del 7,6%
anual en julio bajo Tres puntos básicos
pero en agosto estuvo cerca de alcanzar
el 8% y pues ya el mes pasado llegó
hasta las dos cifras que estamos
mencionando ahora interanual la noticia
positiva pese a todo este panorama
negativo para el bolsillo de los
alemanes es que los depósitos de gas de
ese país ya alcanzaron el 95% de su
capacidad una meta que se logró dos
semanas antes de la fecha prevista por
el gobierno germano y que según el
cancillers con eso se garantiza el
suministro suficiente para los hogares Y
las Industrias durante la temporada de
invierno en nuestra región chile subió
la tasa de interés para así frenar la
inflación tratar de hacerlo seguimos
hablando de inflación como ha visto son
bastantes datos de varios países
siguiendo los pasos de la reserva
federal y pues sus pares en la región El
Banco Central de chile decidió subir su
tasa de interés referencial en 50 puntos
básicos de esta manera paso del 10,75%
al 11,25% para tratar de frenar la
inflación que en septiembre acumuló un
13,7% interanual el país queda así con
una de las tasas de interés más altas de
América Latina y con el el mayor nivel
desde 2001 el emisor chileno sin embargo
si difiere de sus vecinos en el sentido
de que pues aseguró que el ciclo de
alzas llega a su fin como muchos otros
bancos centrales del mundo el chileno
había hecho un drástico recorte de la
tasa hasta el mínimo histórico del 0,5%
durante la pandemia vamos a ver ahora
los indicadores económicos Así es porque
todos están regidos por el dato de
inflación que acabamos de hablar en este
momento Wall Street abrió en rojo con el
mercado de bursátil tomando las
decisiones con aquel dato que estamos
hablando Aunque bajó pues se ubicó por
encima de lo previsto por la reserva
Federal de ese país las bolsas europeas
siguieron operando pero sus tres
principales indicadores registran
pérdidas decisiones que tomaron debido
también al dato de inflación de la
principal Economía del mundo y también
la inflación de Europa la principal
economía de Europa las bolsas asiáticas
cerraron en rojo con los mercados
temerosos previos a conocer el dato de
inflación de Estados Unidos ellos
cerraron antes del dato que acabamos de
mencionar Y pues también numerosos de
que la reserva Federal aumente las tasas
de interés para cerrar que nos trae como
cifradía 8 millones de dólares le
costará a Argentina transmitir gratis el
mundial de fútbol 2022 con esto los
argentinos podrán ver 32 de los 64
partidos de la Copa del Mundo a través
de la televisión pública sin necesidad
de pagar alguna tarifa especial por
ellos Juan Pablo como siempre Muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica mañana Claro que sí más
economía Así es nos vamos a París Ahí
está nuestra periodista Erico olavarría
para hablar de lo que está ocurriendo en
torno a los combustibles
[Música]